[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing powerful spells
however we're not just going to be
discussing any old powerful spells
we're going to be discussing the most
powerful fire
related spells elemental magic is a huge
part of harry potter
we see all sorts of water and fire
related spells crop
up across the series this list will
include spells from all of harry potter
canon
including fantastic beasts without
further ado let's get into it
number 5 bluebell flames starting off in
rather innocent fashion
we have bluebell flames a simple spell
which produces a blue flame
that's able to singe objects bluebell
flames are considered to be
less powerful than real fire but the
advantage
is that they are waterproof they could
be touched and even held by the caster
without any risk of burning themselves
however
the spell could be used to singe
materials
like oh i don't know robes the spell is
notably used by hermione granger on
professor severus snape
when she set his robes on fire during
the gryffindor southern quidditch match
she also used this same spell on the
devil's snare
protecting the philosopher's stone she
whipped out her wand
waved it muttered something and sent a
jet of the same
bluebell flames she had used on snape at
the plant
in a matter of seconds the two boys felt
it loosening its grip
as it cringed away from the light and
warmth
this spell is actually pretty innocent
but it is useful
and given that it has far more
application than some of the other basic
fire spells
it earns a spot on the list however i
will say this
the spells get a lot more powerful from
here on out
number four gubrathian fire derived from
the scottish gaelic phrase
gubrath which means forever gubrathian
fire
is just that a flame that will burn for
eternity
it also goes by the name everlasting
fire and will burn forever
via special enchantment supposedly the
fire will even continue to burn
after the caster dies in terms of harry
potter magic
this is extremely powerful and while it
may not be perfect for combat
the prospect of fire that literally
burns forever
and can't be put out makes it extremely
enigmatic
additionally it was extremely advanced
magic and very difficult to cast in fact
very few wizards were capable of casting
it as far as its place in the story
dumbledore gave hagrid a branch
enchanted with this fire
as a gift to the giants a gift that went
down
quite well dumbledore quite
unsurprisingly
was able to cast it dumbledore bewitched
this branch to burn
forever more which isn't something any
wizard could do
though i believe the spell was too
powerful to be taught to students at
hogwarts
it was mentioned in class by flitwick in
numerous
charms lessons number three fiend fire
a slight step up from the last spell in
terms of power
we have fiend fire one of the most
powerful spells in the entire
harry potter universe it was not normal
fire
crab had used a curse which harry had no
knowledge
as they turned a corner the flames
chased them as though they were alive
sentient intent upon killing them now
the fire was mutating
forming a gigantic pack of fiery beasts
flaming serpents
chimeras and dragons rose and fell and
rose again
and the detritus of centuries on which
they were feeding
was thrown up in the air into their
fanged mouths
tossed high on cooled feet before being
consumed by the inferno
for those unaware fiendfire is absurdly
overpowered
and its basic function is to destroy
everything
voldemort is an earned proponent of the
spell and can be seen using it against
dumbledore
in their epic duel in the ministry
atrium fiendfire produces enchanted
flames of an enormous scale
that essentially destroy anything in its
path often taking the form of gigantic
fiery beasts
that are semi-sentient in addition to
all of the above
it has been expressed the flames are
entirely inextinguishable by water
scary while it doesn't sound like you
can get much more powerful than this
turns out it actually can number two
firestorm aka fire rope in the harry
potter books and films
we see dumbledore's mastery of elemental
magic on numerous occasions
but first in his ministry atrium jewel
against voldemort
and then his encounter with the end
fairy in the cave
however one of the most impressive
spells that stuck out to me
was firestorm aka fire rope
the two names seem to be largely
conflated between book and film
but then through the darkness fire
erupted
crimson and gold a ring of fire
surrounded the rock
so that the in fairy holding harry so
tightly stumbled
and vaulted dumbledore was on his feet
again
pale as any of the surrounding in fairy
but taller than any
two the fire dancing in his eyes his
wand was raised like a torch
and from its tip emanated the flames
like a vast lasso encircling them all
with warmth
firestorm otherwise known as lasso of
flames or
fire rope is an incandation that
produces a large ring of fire
from the caster's wand when the caster
moves the ring of fire moves with them
and will effectively ward off anyone
trying to hurt them
while the ring of fire circles them the
caster also holds the ability to
shoot individual jets or balls of flames
at their opponents
this ability pairs well with party's
temporus
which allows a gap in the flames of the
caster to safely pass through
dumbledore used this spell to ward off
the masses of inveri who were guarding
the horcrux
even in his weakened state this spell
proved to be more than enough to serve
its purpose
number one protego diabolica topping the
list of fire spells today
is actually one of the derivations of
protego
i know what you're thinking isn't
protego just a shield charm
where's the fire yes you're certainly
right protego
is just a shield charm however there are
many levels of the spell
and basically the more powerful you are
the more likely it is to be able to cast
one of the high
level versions protego regular is a
defensive ability that any witch or
wizard should possess
in their magical arsenal it blocks
physical entities
reflects spells and even rebounds
conjurations
back towards the caster protego duo is
just a slightly more advanced form of
the regular protego
protego totalim is where things start to
pivot towards more of a protective
shield type spell
protego maxima is a more powerful
version of protego totalim
protego horribilis is the most powerful
of the traditional
protective shield formats and protego
diabolica
is a whole other animal and the fire
spell in question
ever heard the adage the best defense is
a good offense
well protego diabolica is unimaginably
strong
in both offensive and defensive settings
it's possibly the most powerful spell
across both harry potter and fantastic
beasts
and we first see it in the crimes of
grindelwald when gelet grindelwald casts
it
inside the lestrange mausoleum the spell
creates a ring of protective black fire
around the target
and anyone who is an enemy of the caster
will be instantly incinerated when they
try to enter the circle
the shield can also be controlled like a
weapon and the caster has the capacity
to extend
10 drills of black flames towards
enemies
anyone struck by one of these tendrils
will suffer the same fate as someone
trying to enter
the circle and if that isn't enough
already the spell
eventually escalates into what can only
be described
as a fiery winged demon with the
capacity to destroy
entire cities though the spell is blue
in the films
it's worth mentioning that it's meant to
be black and that's it for this video
i hope you enjoyed the list did i miss
any spells
what's your list let me know in the
comment section below
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you